my question is related to risk which of
course is an important part of the
business world and how you manage risk
in your philanthropy so specifically I
was wondering whether you have a
preference between investing in an
individual and maybe that individuals
one brilliant idea or in a more stable
investment say a larger group that's
well established I think we want to
invest a lot in leaders and that leader
could be an individual that leader could
be the head of a you know enormous
organization but for my husband and I we
it really is very important that we
believe in the person themselves who is
executing and we're willing to put our
money where we think somebody can
deliver what they're offering to deliver
I mean they're really kind of it's it's
like an investment in a business in some
sense because they're people want to
invest in the team and that's what I
want to do I want to invest in the team
I want to believe it's somebody who can
really do what what they say they can do
and so for us we've invested both in
very very large organizations we've
supported and we've supported some very
small organizations too and we see
somebody who we think is really
passionate and really capable and
executing well and a mission that's
consistent with the things that we're
trying to accomplish we'll do that as
well that we wouldn't be restricted by
that at all but if we see an
organization where we don't think the
leadership is very good then we wouldn't
go there the other thing we do which I
think is interesting is we really do due
diligence on people who we you know give
money to so we want to see their books
we want to see that they're profitable
we want to see not profitable that their
breakeven that they're not you know
losing money we want to see that their
they've got good governance that they've
got systems in place to review their CEO
that they are thinking about a board and
how they get good board members on it
that you know we like to see good
governance in an organization to know
that it can endure to know that if it
runs into difficulties that it's going
to get through those difficulties and
it's going to go on this though
is potentially problematic because isn't
it okay to have a limited time span
because there are some entities that
should in fact exist but exist for a
limited duration and I'm sure you
wouldn't disagree with that that it's
okay if that lifespan is five years or
ten years with with it with what if
they've they've resolved the issue that
they were set up to be right yes but
that would need to be deliberate I mean
I think the organization would say to
itself okay here's our mission when when
our mission is accomplished we're gonna
fold up shop and go away mind you I
think that never happens I think it
should happen more than it does happen
because organizations have a way of
perpetuating themselves they have a way
of saying okay well let's find something
else to do if we were done with this
thing but you know let's say
hypothetically an organization came to
terms of that and said this is our this
is what we want to accomplish and let's
get through it and accomplish it good
governance wouldn't prevent you from
from achieving that good governance
would enable you to achieve that in my
view